[Music]  well new at four move over iowa and new  hampshire if nevada democrats have their  way  we will become the first in the nation  primary state  right now political parties in nevada  choose their candidate for president  through caucuses there's been a push to  move to primaries to include  more people last year many complained  the caucuses took  too long as people waited hours in line  assembly speaker jason fryerson  releasing this  statement quote nevada's diverse  population and first-hand experience in  issues relating to climate change public  lands immigration  and health care provide a unique voice  that deserves to be heard first  if the bill passes nevada's primaries  would happen  the second to last week in january